We now come to our last major
class of counting problems.
We will count the number of ways
that a given set can be
partitioned into pieces
of given sizes.
We start with a set
that consists
of n different elements.
And we have r persons.
We want to give n1 items to
the first person, give n2
items to the second
person, and so on.
And finally, we want
to give n-sub-r
items to the rth person.
These numbers, n1, n2, up to nr
are given to us, how many
items each person should get.
And these numbers must add to
n so that every item in the
original set is given
to some person.
We want to count to the number
of ways that this can be done.
This is the number of ways that
we can partition a given
set into subsets of
prescribed sizes.
Let's use c to denote
the number of
ways this can be done.
We want to calculate
this number c.
Instead of calculating directly,
we're going to use
the same trick that we employed
when we counted
combinations and derived the
binomial coefficient.
That is, we're going to
consider, in a much simpler
counting problem, the problem
of ordering n items, taking
the n items in our original
set and putting them in an
ordered list.
Of course, we know in how many
ways this can be done.
Ordering n items can be done
in n factorial ways.
This is the count
of the number of
permutations of n items.
But now let us think of a
different way of ordering the
n items, an indirect way.
It proceeds according to
the following stages.
We start with the n items.
And we first distribute them
to the different persons.
Having done that, then we ask
person one to take their
items, order them, and put
them in the first n1
slots of our list.
Then person two takes their
items and puts them into the
next n2 slots in our list.
We continue this way.
And finally, the last person
takes the items that they
possess and puts them
in the last n-sub-r
slots in this list.
In how many ways can this
process be carried out?
We have c choices on how
to partition the
given set into subsets.
Then person one has n1 factorial
choices on how to
order the n1 items that
that person processes.
Person two has n2 factorial
choices for how to order the
n2 items that it possesses,
and so on until the last
person, who has nr factorial
choices for
ordering their elements.
This multi-stage process results
in an ordered list of
the n terms.
This is the number of ways these
multi-stage process can
be carried out.
On the other hand, we know that
the number of possible
orderings of the items
is n factorial.
So we have this equality.
We can solve this for c.
And we find the answer, that the
number of ways that the n
items can be partitioned into
subsets of the given sizes is
n factorial divided by the
product of the factorials of
the different ni's.
This particular expression
is called the multinomial
coefficient, and it generalizes
the binomial
coefficient.
The binomial coefficient was
referring to the case where we
essentially split our set into
one subset with k elements,
and then the second subset gets
the remaining elements.
So the special case where r is
equal to 2, and n1 is equal to
k, n2 equals to n minus k,
this corresponds to a
partition of a set into two
subsets, or what is the same
just selecting the first subset
and putting everything
else in the second subset.
And you can check that in this
particular case, the
expression for the multinomial
coefficient agrees with the
expression that we had derived
for the binomial coefficient.